bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP à l'ordre du jour de la séance
publique mardi 6 décembre la politique
de l'immigration éternelle sujet de
débat en attendant la présentation d'un
projet de loi prévu début 2023 la
première ministre lève le voile sur les
mesures envisagées par l'exécutif la
parole est à Elisabeth borne madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés
le sujet dont nous nous apprêtons à
débattre est essentiel il est l'objet
d'interrogations de discussions et
parfois de passion
parler d'immigration c'est parler de
trajectoire personnelle ou familiale
c'est parler de nos valeurs de notre
droit et de notre histoire
notre pays a toujours accueilli et
intégré toujours délivrer des titres de
ces jours avec des périodes d'arrivée
parfois plus marquées parfois moins
soutenu la France est et restera fidèle
à sa tradition d'asile mais il est
légitime de se poser la question de
notre politique migratoire dire qui on
veut qui on peut accueillir et qui on ne
veut pas qui on ne peut pas accueillir
débattre d'immigration ce n'est pas se
limiter à un sujet la question renvoie
aux causes profondes des mouvements
migratoires à l'efficacité des
politiques de développement pour lutter
contre la peau pauvreté ou les
conséquences du changement climatique et
à l'indispensable coopération avec les
pays d'origine et de transit elle est
liée à nos frontières et à la manière
dont nous devons les faire respecter
elle interroge l'efficacité de nos
procédures juridiques et de notre droit
elle soulève la question centrale de
l'intégration
dans quelques semaines le gouvernement
présentera un texte sur notre politique
migratoire les ministres reviendront
dans un instant sur ces principes
directeurs
pour construire ce projet de loi
plusieurs ministres sont en effet
mobilisés et une large concertation est
en cours je l'avais annoncé dès cet été
le ministre de l'Intérieur la conduit
avec l'appui de la secrétaire d'État à
la citoyenneté le ministre du Travail
c'est également engagé pour discuter des
mesures concernant son champ nous
voulons que le futur texte prolonge les
améliorations de la loi Asie
l'immigration votez lors du premier
quinquennat nous voulons qu'il adapte
notre droit aux évolutions et défis
actuels de la question migratoire
en un mot nous visons l'efficacité les
mesures utiles et les effets concrets
nous ne cherchons pas à cliver ou à
multiplier des mesures uniquement
symboliques ce texte sera équilibré nous
restons fidèles à nos valeurs et à notre
volonté d'intégrer mais on ne peut
intégrer dignement que si notre droit
est respecté fermement
il me paraissait donc important
essentiel même avant la finalisation du
projet de loi et comme je m'y étais
engagé de venir devant la représentation
nationale pour vous présenter des faits
des orientations et pour en débattre
présenter des faits d'abord parce que ce
débat ne peut se reposer sur des
impressions ou des peurs je le dis
d'emblée l'immigration zéro n'est ni
souhaitable ni possible pas plus
réaliste que ne l'est une immigration
déréguréulée ces promesses illusoires
sont mensongères démagogiques et
dangereuses à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale Elisabeth borne fustige les
positions les postures sur l'immigration
illégale elle dénonce les positions de
l'extrême droite notamment sur les auqtf
les obligations de quitter le territoire
ou encore sur l'ame l'aide médicale
d'État
particulièrement à l'extrême droite
c'est 12 derniers mois ont été
foisonnants en contre-vérité et en
propos indignes la fermeté ça n'est pas
la haine de l'autre le respect de nos
frontières ce n'est pas le repli et
l'intégration pleine et entière de ce
que nous accueillons c'est le devoir de
notre pays
nous aurons des désaccords
c'est la démocratie mais c'est
désaccords doivent émerger sur la base
de fées alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés commençons par là commençons par
les faits
oui il existe une immigration légale je
le dis car à entendre certains on
l'oublierait cette immigration légale ce
sont des salariés qualifiés ou encore
les personnes que les Françaises et les
Français ont choisi d'épouser Jean
j'entends souvent dire que le nombre de
titres délivrés à progresser c'est juste
la tendance ne date pas d'hier et elle
s'est vérifiée sous des majorités de
gauche comme de droite ainsi en 15 ans
le nombre de titres de séjour délivrés
est passé de façon progressive de 172
000 en 2007 à 271 000 en 2021
mais ne nous trompons pas sur les causes
de cette augmentation
contrairement aux caricatures
l'immigration familiale a baissé sur
cette période s'il y a eu une
augmentation c'est pour trois raisons
d'abord parce que notre enseignement
supérieur est attractif et que depuis
2017 le nombre d'étudiants que nous
accueillons à doubler c'est une bonne
nouvelle ces étudiants apprennent à
parler français à connaître notre pays
et le font rayonner dans le monde
deuxième raison de cette hausse le
nombre de salariés qualifiés et de
chercheurs que nous accueillons à
augmenter en 15 ans et cela a bénéficié
à notre économie à nos entreprises et à
notre innovation
enfin dernière raison de cette hausse
l'augmentation modérée du nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'asile ce sont 30 000
personnes menacées dans leur pays que
nous accueillons chaque année c'est
l'honneur de la France de leur donner
leur place c'est l'honneur de notre pays
d'avoir accueilli 3000 ressortissants
afghan juste après la chute de Kaboul
l'an dernier c'est l'honneur de la
France d'avoir accueilli 108 000
Ukrainiens depuis le 24 février dernier
sous le statut de protection temporaire
au nom du gouvernement je tiens à
remercier l'OFPRA les élus locaux les
associations et les employeurs qui les
accompagnent au quotidien
bien sûr nous devons donner à toutes les
personnes arriver légalement les moyens
d'une intégration digne et complète
certaines difficultés existent encore
notamment en termes d'insertion
professionnelle j'y reviendrai
je veux encore tordre le cou à une
dernière idée reçue non l'aide médicale
d'État ne nourrit pas l'immigration
irrégulière c'est une question de
protection et de santé publique aucun
projet migratoire vers la France n'est
seulement motivé par l'existence de ce
dispositif dans les conditions d'accès
et les modalités de contrôle ont été
renforcées récemment
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
quels sont les faits concernant
l'immigration légale mais le principal
enjeu ça n'est pas tant la situation de
ceux à qui nous avons délivré un titre
que celle des personnes qui se
maintiennent sur notre territoire sans y
avoir droit ces personnes ne sont pas
éligibles à l'asile il aura souvent été
explicitement refusé pourtant le flux de
demande augmente nettement ces dernières
années et celles et ceux à qui nous
n'accordons pas la protection reste
encore trop fréquemment sur notre
territoire
souvent victime de passeurs qui leur
promettent l'Eldorado et mettent en
danger leur vie la plupart d'entre eux
vivent dans la grande précarité sont
disposés du droit à travailler et
parfois sombre dans la délinquance dans
son discours à l'Assemblée nationale
Elisabeth borne se targue d'avoir trouvé
le bon équilibre entre expulsion et
intégration le gouvernement espère
convaincre un maximum de députés sur ce
sujet sensible de l'immigration face à
ce défi les amateurs de solutions toutes
faites sont nombreux on trouve les
partisans du yakafocon qui voudraient
renvoyer d'un seul coup d'un seul
l'intégralité d'entre eux oui je
souhaite que le droit et nos frontières
soient respectés oui je souhaite des
éloignements rapides et efficaces des
personnes en situation irrégulière mais
non on ne peut pas prétendre que les
choses soient simples comme si nous
pouvions nous affranchir de
l'indispensable coopération des pays
d'origine et des règles de l'État de
droit
de l'autre côté certains appellent à des
opérations de régularisation massive je
le dis aussi clairement il n'en n'est
pas question nous ne créerons pas de
telles précédents qui ne régleraient pas
les difficultés des personnes concernées
qui donneraient des arguments au pasteur
et qui ne seraient ni acceptés ni
acceptable par les français pour notre
part nous voulons prendre le sujet à
bras le corps et proposer des solutions
utiles et efficaces
je crois que nous pouvons nous retrouver
sur une préoccupation commune
évitez que des étrangers restent
durablement dans une situation
indéterminée qui ne serait ni le droit
au séjour ni l'éloignement aussi nous
voulons clarifier beaucoup plus vite la
situation des étrangers arrivés sur
notre sol d'une part nous voulons
accélérer les procédures d'examen des
demandes d'asile et du droit au séjour
pour lutter contre les pratiques
dilatoires et d'autre part une fois la
situation clarifiée nous souhaitons
éloigner plus rapidement ce qui doivent
l'être quant aux personnes qui ont
vocation à rester nous voulons engager
plutôt les actions pour réussir leur
intégration d'abord par la langue et par
l'emploi
c'est principe sont les grands axes de
travail du gouvernement ce sont des
objectifs qui je le crois peuvent
rassembler largement sur ses bancs
mesdames et messieurs les députés comme
l'a dit le président de la République
nous devons déployer une action complète
cohérente et efficace en amont des flux
migratoires et après l'arrivée sur notre
territoire
nous voulons d'abord prévenir les
départs irréguliers en contribuant grâce
à notre aide publique au développement à
traiter les causes profondes des
migrations que sont la pauvreté et de
plus en plus les effets du dérèglement
climatique la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères il reviendra
ensuite nous devons mieux protéger nos
frontières pour y parvenir notre premier
levier d'action est européen
pendant la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne nous
sommes parvenus à plusieurs avancées
autour du pacte sur la migration et
l'asile en particulier pour rendre plus
efficace les contrôles à l'arrivée en
Europe et pour renforcer les mécanismes
de solidarité pour les états de première
entrée pourvu que ces états respectent
le droit maritime nous devrons notamment
tirer toutes les conséquences de
l'accueil de Lucian viking
nous devons maintenant continuer nous
poussons pour un renforcement des moyens
de Frontex et pour une réforme de
l'espace Schengen nous voulons également
consolider le système d'asile européen
c'est aussi à l'échelle européenne que
nous lutterons plus efficacement contre
les réseaux de passeurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna et la secrétaire
d'État en charge de l'Europe Laurence
Boone sont pleinement mobilisés en ce
sens
le deuxième moyen d'action c'est au
niveau national en renforçant le
contrôle à nos frontières et en
accélérant les procédures en novembre
2020 le président de la République a
annoncé le doublement des effectifs à
nos frontières et une nouvelle fois les
résultats sont là 10 000 refus par mois
ont été prononcés en 2021 contre 3000
début 2020 avant le covid ensuite nous
devons accélérer les procédures
d'examens des demandes d'asile dans ce
domaine des progrès ont été réalisés
dans le précédent quinquennat les délais
de l'OFPRA ont considérablement diminué
mais ceux des procédures contentieuses
sont encore trop longs au total le délai
moyen de traitement d'une demande
d'asile est encore de l'ordre d'un an
nous devons donc accélérer et viser un
délai global de 6 mois pour l'ensemble
de la procédure nous voulons notamment
réformer le contentieux des étrangers
pour le réduire et le simplifier nous
voulons passer de 12 procédures
contentieuses à 4 suivant en cela les
présentation du Conseil d'État et du
rapport du président de la commission
des Lois du Sénat François Noël buffet
le ministre de l'Intérieur il reviendra
et travaillent également avec le
ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti à une réforme de la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile enfin
nous voulons éloigner plus
systématiquement et plus efficacement
les personnes déboutées du droit d'asile
nous devons augmenter nos capacités en
centre de rétention administrative et
nous continuerons à agir dans nos
relations bilatérales avec les pays qui
refusent de réadmettre leurs propres
ressortissants
par ailleurs nous devons être
intraitables avec les étrangers
délinquants même en situation régulière
s'engager dans la délinquance c'est se
placer en dehors de notre communauté
nationale c'est porter une atteinte
grave à notre pacte social et à nos
compatriotes c'est également nuit à tous
les étrangers qui vivent en France et
qui construisent paisiblement des
parcours d'intégration réussie dont on
ne parle pas grâce à l'action déterminée
du ministre de l'Intérieur et des
préfets plus de 3000 étrangers auteurs
de troubles à l'ordre public ont été
éloignés en 2021 et 2022 enfin sous le
contrôle du juge et dans le respect de
nos engagements conventionnels des
mesures d'expulsion doivent désormais
pouvoir être prises contre les étrangers
quel que soit leur situation qui
commettent des infractions graves
mesdames et messieurs les députés je le
disais nous portons une vision
équilibrée si nous voulons que ceux qui
ne doivent pas rester partout c'est
aussi pour pouvoir mieux intégrer ce que
nous accueillons cela passe d'abord par
une refonte en profondeur de l'accueil
en préfecture pour les démarches de
renouvellement des titres des étrangers
en situation régulière
nous devons éviter les pertes de droit
notamment d'emploi que peuvent connaître
certaines personnes faute d'accès au
guichet
pour les demandeurs d'asile nous devons
aussi continuer à renforcer nos
capacités d'hébergement en cinq ans nous
les avons déjà augmentés de plus de
36000 places enfin le pivot de notre
politique d'intégration c'est le travail
dans un pays dont le taux de chômage est
de 7,3% nous devons d'abord chercher à
pourvoir les postes vacants en proposant
ses emplois à nous ressortissants et aux
personnes en situation régulière le taux
d'emploi des immigrés en France et 9
points plus faibles que celui de
l'ensemble de la population nous devons
travailler à réduire cet écart ensuite
si les employeurs ne sont pas parvenus à
trouver la main d'oeuvre dont ils ont
besoin ils peuvent la faire venir de
manière légale un employeur peut
toujours solliciter une autorisation de
travail s'il démontre qu'il n'a pas pu
pour voir le poste en déposant une
oeuvre une offre auprès de Pôle Emploi
pour certains métiers particulièrement
en tension l'employeur est même dispensé
de cette justification et nous avons
simplifié ces dis en 2019 pour mieux
répondre aux besoins enfin la question
de la régularisation peut se poser pour
des personnes en situation irrégulière
présente sur notre sol depuis des années
et qui travaille depuis longtemps et
avant que l'extrême droite ne tente une
nouvelle manipulation je le redis il ne
s'agit en aucun cas d'une régularisation
massive ni de laisser penser que la
régularisation serait la réponse aux
tensions sur le marché du travail il
s'agit de régulariser certaines
personnes qui de contribuent depuis
longtemps à la richesse nationale mais
qui subissent parfois des conditions de
travail indignes et restent enfermés
dans un statut précaire
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
il reviendra plus en détail enfin
mesdames et messieurs les députés
s'intégrer c'est parler la langue de la
République alors que nous proposons des
cours de langue dès l'arrivée sur le
territoire nous souhaitons qu'un niveau
minimal de Français soit désormais
imposé pour obtenir des titres de séjour
de plus d'un an
mesdames et messieurs les députés
cherchez des mesures efficaces vouloir
une immigration régulée maîtrisée ça
n'est ni manquait de fermeté ni manquait
d'humanité c'est l'expression de notre
volonté de voir nos frontières et notre
doigt droit respecter c'est
l'intransigence face à ceux qui se place
en dehors des lois de la République mais
c'est aussi la fidélité à nos valeurs et
à notre histoire c'est accueillir et
intégrer celles et ceux qui sont menacés
ou victimes de persécution ou encore
celles et ceux qui contribuent au
rayonnement et à la vitalité économique
de notre pays cet équilibre s'accommode
mal des postures politiciennes ils
demandent du travail et des réflexions
sérieuses et de bonne foi il demande des
discussions fondées sur les faits et non
pas sur les peurs il demande la
recherche de solutions efficaces au-delà
des dogmes et des idéologies cet
équilibre c'est la condition pour
creuser le sillon de notre l'histoire et
atteindre l'objectif que nous
recherchons tous l'intégration de celles
et ceux que nous accueillons si nous
acceptons ces principes je suis certaine
que nous pourrons trouver cet équilibre
soyons à la hauteur de l'enjeu je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
le gouvernement veut mieux intégrer mais
aussi mieux expulser selon la formule de
Gérald Darmanin l'exécutive envisage de
délivrer une obligation de quitter le
territoire dès le premier refus de la
demande d'asile sans attendre
d'éventuelles recours notamment pour les
étrangers qui commettent des infractions
graves la parole est à Gérald Darmanin
mesdames et messieurs les députés
le peuple français est un composé
c'est mieux que race c'est une nation
unique en Europe la conformation de la
France se prêtait à tous les échanges de
courant du sang et ceux des idées la
France est à Nice une voix de grande
communication entre le nord et le midi
ainsi commence l'histoire de France de
Bainville et comme lui ne pensons
qu'immigration fait partie de la France
et des Français
et depuis toujours
l'immigration est un fait qui fait aussi
la France qui a fait son passé et qui
fera sans doute son avenir
et il ne sert à rien d'être contre
en effet que veut dire être contre le
mouvement des hommes sur la Terre qu'il
fuit pour une partie d'entre eux à cause
de la misère de la persécution ou des
événements climatiques
[Applaudissements]
à quoi cela sert-il d'être contre
lorsque depuis le premier janvier 2022
et quel que soit les gouvernements qui
soient gérés par l'extrême droite ou par
la gauche il y a plus 68% de demande
d'asile en Europe
que signifie en effet d'être contre
l'arrivée de médecins d'infirmiers de
maçon devriez agricoles qui travaillent
dans les vignes par exemple ou des
prêtres
quand la France manque cruellement de
tous ces métiers de toutes ces vocations
cela ne signifie en rien que
la peur de altérité ou pire encore le
mensonge démagogique de ceux qui jouent
sur les peurs
non l'immigration n'est pas ce que les
démagogues disent
en revanche disons plutôt que
l'immigration est un contrat
un contrat librement consenti par celui
qui souhaite venir en France et le pays
qui veut l'accueillir
et puisque la France entre grand pays
attire grâce à ses valeurs
grâce à son économie
grâce à sa promesse d'avenir
définissons ensemble les exigences
qu'ils ont celles de notre nation pour
accueillir les étrangers
c'est l'ambition du projet de loi que
nous a demandé d'écrire madame la
Première ministre et monsieur le
Président de la République que nous vous
présenterons avec Olivier du soft
d'abord la première exigence de la
France c'est celle de faire respecter
ses règles ses valeurs et son droit
nul ne peut prétendre rester durablement
sur notre sol s'il ne respecte pas les
valeurs de la République
comme tous les pays notre relation
demande à être respectée
ici les femmes ont les droits
équivalents aux hommes la liberté
sexuelle est totale la liberté
religieuse aussi
que ceux qui commettent des crimes et
des délits prennent conscience qui ne
peuvent pas rester sur le territoire
national car quand les commettant il ne
commettent pas seulement un crime
il commet un crime contre notre propre
accueil
depuis 5 ans 80000 titres de séjour ont
été retirés pour cause d'ordre public ou
de radicalisation
3100 criminels au terroristes ont été
expulsés
mais trop trop de règles spécifiquement
françaises empêche d'expulser un
criminels sur notre sol
tout en respectant absolument l'article
8 de la Convention de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme ne vous proposerons
dans le texte de loi que nous mettrons à
l'ordre du jour de la semaine nationale
du Sénat de ne plus nous censurer et de
laisser au juge de soin de mesurer si la
vie privée est familiale et le droit au
séjour sont compatibles avec les actes
de graves de vacances qui seront faites
faites aux femmes et aux enfants les
violences sur les policiers les
gendarmes ou les pompiers
faites au nom des crimes du code pénal
ou des trafics de stupéfiants
les propositions législatives que nous
proposerons au nom du ministère de
l'Intérieur seront évidemment proposés
aussi par monsieur le garde des sceaux
pour le volet judiciaire
la fin de la fin de la double peine
c'est en fait pas simplement réclamé par
les Français
elle est aussi et surtout par l'immense
majorité de nos compatriotes étrangers
qui souhaitent ne plus jamais être
confondus avec ceux qui ruinent leur
réputation et leurs efforts parce que
quelques-uns autour de ce comportent mal
il faudrait donc qu'ils en payent le
prix le racisme et la xénophobie
augmente quand l'État se montre peu
capable de châtier les délinquants et
laisse l'amalgame se faire entre tous
les étrangers il faut avoir vécu loin
des quartiers populaires pour ne pas
voir que
malheureusement
l'absence de réponse de la loi fait
aussi monter les extrêmes
deuxième exigence
être étranger sur le sol national c'est
parler la langue du pays
et faire des efforts d'intégration
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
25% des étrangers en situation régulière
parlent très mal ou écrivent très mal le
français
comment voulez-vous bâtir un parcours
mais vous devriez plutôt vous réjouir
des propositions d'intégration du
gouvernement plutôt que plutôt Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires de la
nupesse
comprendre avant la même la fin de la
phrase qu'il s'agit d'une belle
proposition du gouvernement
je vais donc repartir devant ce constat
25% des étrangers en situation régulière
parlent très mal ou écrivent très mal le
français comment voulez-vous bâtir un
parcours de vie professionnelle
personnel et j'allais dire citoyen avec
un tel handicap
l'etame mettra donc les moyens sans
précédent pour améliorer l'intégration
par la langue avec l'augmentation des
heures de français obligatoires
nous augmentons de 25% le budget de
l'intégration pour plus de 100 millions
d'euros dès les trois prochaines années
et nous rapprochons ainsi de nos voisins
comme l'Allemagne et l'Italie qui
exigent un examen désormais de français
pour avoir un titre de séjour long
cette mesure n'existe pas s'il existe un
test il ne conditionne pas le titre de
séjour désormais tout étranger qui
passera un titre qui voudra passer
pardon à titre de séjour long sur le
territoire national devra passer un
examen de français qu'il devra réussir
le ministre du Travail vous évoquera
sans doute le ministre du Travail vous
évoquera sans doute le fait que nous
demanderons au patronat de contribuer
évidemment à cette révolution
linguistique pour que chacune et chacun
se sentent profondément bien dans notre
pays
70 000 étrangers par an seront donc
concernés plus 200 000 étrangers qui
demandent le renouvellement de leur
titre de séjour 270
000 personnes seront donc concernées par
l'examen de français pour cet examen
avec la langue vous allez principe
en cas de rejet des principes de la
République la loi permettra demain si
vous adoptez ce texte de retirer un
titre de séjour si les étrangers ne
respectent pas les principes de la
République tels que définir la loi
séparatisme
cette notion recouvre l'obligation de
respecter les principes de la République
dont la dignité de la personne humaine
notre laïcité mais aussi notre hymne
national notre drapeau et notre emblème
troisième exigence de la République
celle du travail et de l'intégration par
le travail le ministre du Travail
reviendra ce principe est important ce
principe est même très important et
Soustons une grande partie du projet de
loi il sera détaillé par lui
avec les exigences demandées aux
étrangers la République doit elle
continuer à mieux s'accueillir faire
davantage d'efforts et être plus humain
d'abord à la demande de la première
ministre une réforme profonde de nos
préfectures et de notre façon
d'accueillir les étrangers seront mises
à l'oeuvre en même temps que la loi
adoptée par le Parlement
ainsi il y aura automaticité du
renouvellement des titres de séjour pour
les étrangers déjà sur le sol national
qui n'attendront plus des nems rendez
vous des files d'attente numérique et
qui connaîtront parfois de grandes
difficultés pour faire entendre leurs
droits et se trouve parfois irrégulier
par l'incurie de l'organisation même de
l'État
plus de personnes qui contrôleront les
primes arrivants et les personnes qui
doivent partir du territoire national
automaticité pour tous ceux qui ont déjà
un titre de séjour voilà le principe de
la réforme des préfectures qui sera mise
en œuvre par le gouvernement
avec le réforme des préfectures vient la
simplification de notre droit madame la
Première ministre largement évoqué je
voudrais revenir évidemment sur la
réforme du droit d'asile il ne s'agit
pas ici de revoir les pays sûrs les
critères pour obtenir l'asile chacun
constatera d'ailleurs que la France en
moyenne donne deux fois moins d'asile
que nos voisins allemands et autant que
nos voisins espagnols et autrichiens
pour un pays qui est plus grand vous
l'avouerez nous ne sommes pas donc
l'axis sur la demande d'asile nous
donnons l'asile à ceux qui le méritent
sur le territoire de la République mais
il faut évidemment
faire une réforme notamment après celle
de l'OFPRA de la CNDA et le garde des
sceaux et moi-même proposeront à la fois
le juge unique tout en laissant la
collégialité pour les arrêts principes à
la demande du Conseil d'État la
territorialisation de la CNDA et la
création d'espace françaises
notre droit doit être plus clair
et rendu plus rapidement
il faut savoir accueillir plus vite ce
qui mérite l'asile il faut évidemment
refuser plus vite ce qui ne peuvent pas
l'avoir sur notre sol c'est en prenant
trop de temps que nous créons en
situation administrative inextricable
des personnes qui peuvent être ni
régularisées ni expulsés et qui viennent
ensuite malheureusement agrandir la
corde de ceux qui sont dans
tous les travaux au noir parfois même la
délinquance que nous faisons ici que
regretter
le droit d'asile refusant
le droit de ainsi refusé vaudra qtf ce
qui voudrait dire une réforme profonde
des voies de recours qui passent en
effet de 12 à 4 et qui empêchera
mécaniquement l'alimentation de flux de
personnes irrégulières sur le territoire
national
enfin son proposition de Monsieur le
gardeesso à la suite du drame de Calais
ou 27 migrants ont trouvé la mort dans
la Manche
les dispositions extrêmement fortes sont
adoptées qui alourdiront dans le code
pénal jusqu'à 20 ans de prison le crime
de passeur qui était aujourd'hui qu'un
délit merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
et je crois
et je crois que ici personne ne peut
être complice des passeurs et
malheureusement je crains que vos cris
ne font qu'encourager
ce qui utilise les personnes humaines
comme de la marchandise ou du bétail et
son responsables malheureusement de
toutes ces disparitions et de tous ces
morts
les reconduites aux frontières doivent
être bien évidemment améliorées même si
depuis le 1er janvier de cette année
c'est 21% de plus de reconduite que
compte le gouvernement par la
simplification du droit et par
l'agglomération de noration diplomatique
merci Madame la mise à faire étrangère
le texte de loi prévoit également de
spécialiser les centres de rétention
administratif depuis mon arrivée au
ministère de l'Intérieur à la demande du
gouvernement
nous allons centraliser dans l'écran
91% au moment où je parle de personnes
délinquante ou criminel et laisser dans
les assignations résidence les étrangers
régulières qui ne posent pas de problème
d'ordre public aussi le projet de loi
prévoiera l'interdiction de placer des
mineurs de moins de 16 ans dans les
centres de rétention administratif
amélioration de notre reconduite
humanisation de notre accueil des
étrangers fermeté envers ceux qui sont
délinquants intégration pour ceux qui
veulent vivre dans notre belle France le
projet de loi que nous présenterons avec
le ministre du Travail et demande de la
preuve ministre permettra j'en suis sûr
d'améliorer très significativement le
service public rendu à tous nos
concitoyens ne verra pas les étrangers
comme des criminels en puissance ne sera
pas non plus naïf contre ceux qui
veulent atteindre la République
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
future loi sur l'immigration a aussi un
objectif économique l'octroi d'un titre
de séjour métier en tension est à
l'étude pour permettre de recruter dans
des secteurs en difficulté comme le
bâtiment ou la restauration explication
à la tribune avec Olivier du socle le
ministre du Travail
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les députés à l'entrée de ce
débat le gouvernement porte une
conviction forte le lien entre travail
et intégration pour évident qu'il soit
doit être réaffirmé parce qu'il est la
seule manière d'assurer sa subsistance
parce qu'il est un formidable moyen
d'apprendre la langue et la culture d'un
peuple nous devons réhabiliter le
travail comme vecteur d'intégration et
c'est d'autant plus juste que
l'immigration a toujours permis à la
France de répondre aux besoins de son
économie nous avons besoin des talents
étrangers sans occulter le fait qu'il
nous faut former et accompagner nos
compatriotes cela reste la priorité de
notre politique de l'emploi et la marche
vers le plein emploi doit évidemment
s'accompagner d'un recours qui reste
subsidiaire recrutement d'étrangers non
communautaire pour faire face à nos
besoins en compétences et en
qualification
cependant il nous faut aussi regarder
notre système avec lucidité et
considérer que ce système en matière
d'immigration pour le travail et par le
travail est inefficace par plusieurs
aspects et injuste par d'autres d'abord
il est efficace car il ne permet pas à
de nombreux primoires vivants arriver
régulièrement sur notre territoire de se
former et d'être accompagné pour exercer
un emploi sur notre territoire le taux
de chômage des immigrés le montre il est
nettement supérieur à celui des
personnes nées en France ainsi au
premier trimestre 2022 il était d'un peu
plus de 13% contre 7,5% pour l'ensemble
de la population et cet écart entre le
taux de chômage des personnes nées à
l'étranger et le taux de chômage
national moyen est un écart qui est
constant quel que soit les conditions de
l'activité économique en période de
crise comment perdre en période de
croissance
ensuite notre système est aussi
inefficace car il enferme dans
l'illégalité des étrangers présentent
depuis longtemps sur notre territoire et
qui travaillent dans des secteurs
d'intention ces personnes qui sont
malheureusement parfois pointées du
doigt dans le cadre du débat que nous
avons ouvert contribue à l'économie
française leur utilité est remarquée et
remarquable elles sont déclarées elles
payent des impôts et leur situation
relève parfois de la traite des êtres
humains pourquoi parce que l'absence de
droit au séjour les rend vulnérables et
précaires des employeurs peu scrupuleux
les oblige à travailler parfois
plusieurs semaines sans repos ou encore
être hébergé dans des conditions
indignes plusieurs décisions de justice
ont mis en exerbes en exergue ça ne vaut
évidemment pas généralisation mais nous
voulons aussi au travers de ce débat et
du texte qui viendra pouvoir condamner
plus sévèrement celles et ceux qui se
livrent ni plus ni moins que de la
traite de la traite d'être humain
ensuite nous voulons progresser parce
que progresser sur ce sujet c'est
progresser sur l'ensemble des conditions
de travail en supprimant ces situations
du pire et en revenant un socle commun
pour l'ensemble des salariés au delà de
celles et ceux qui connaissent
aujourd'hui une situation irrégulière et
sur lesquelles je reviendrai il nous
faut aussi simplifier l'accès au travail
en réexaminant la question les
autorisations préalables exigées pour la
conclusion de chaque contrat de travail
dans le cadre de l'immigration légale et
des cartes de séjour plus réelles dans
les secteurs qui ont largement recours
au contrats cette obligation de demander
une autorisation préalable avant chaque
contrat de travail peut agir en vérité
comme une véritable trappe un travail
dissimulé
j'évoquais leur situation il y a un
instant mais il nous faut donc sortir de
l'absure de l'absurde de jeu perdant
perdants qui concerne la situation
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
dans des métiers qui manquent réellement
de main d'oeuvre des étrangers présents
depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire travaillant depuis plusieurs
mois en France dans un métier en tension
sont parfois en situation irrégulière et
sans porte de sortie il travaille
s'intègre sont intégrés et ils demeure
pourtant son droit au séjour ni au
travail la procédure d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour dites
circulaires Valls est aujourd'hui
appliqué de façon hétérogène sur le
territoire et laisse de surcroît un
grand pouvoir à l'employeur puisque
celui-ci doit soutenir la démarche ce
que ne font pas les plus indélicats
d'entre eux c'est la raison pour
laquelle il nous parais souhaitable que
ces étrangers puissent obtenir un titre
de séjour temporaire pour une année
renouvelable il s'agirait de leur
permettre de travailler dans un métier
en tension de main d'oeuvre il pourrait
ensuite s'insérer dans un parcours plus
classique toujours par le travail et par
la langue ça s'appelle tout simplement
l'intégration et c'est ce que nous
voulons promouvoir comme nous l'avons
indiqué assez récemment avec monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur
nous y travaillons et les concertations
sont en cours mais d'ores et déjà nous
pouvons affirmer qu'il faudra résident
en France depuis plusieurs années pour
baiser bénéficier de ce titre et il
travaillait depuis plusieurs mois il ne
s'agit pas d'un plan de régularisation
massive mais d'une solution donnée à
celle c'est ceux qui sont déjà là qui
travaillent depuis longtemps et qui sont
parfois aussi devenus réguliers en
raison de la complexité des formalités
ou d'accidents de parcours certains
teignes de pensée que nous allons
favoriser le travail des étrangers au
détriment du travail des Français là
aussi c'est un mensonge ou une façon de
faire peur ce type de séjour
s'appliquera à ceux qui travaillent déjà
dans des secteurs en tension des
secteurs où les témoignages
d'entreprises rencontrant des
difficultés de recrutement sont nombreux
c'est d'ailleurs une forte demande de
nombre d'entreprises et non particulier
dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration
c'est aussi dans cet état d'esprit que
nous avons d'ores et déjà initier la
révision de la liste existante des
métiers en tension les textes
prévoyantes qu'elles soient à intervalle
régulier pour être aussi adapté que
possible cette liste nous sera utile
pour déterminer l'accès au titre de
séjour que je viens d'évoquer cette
liste est déjà utile pour permettre à
des employeurs qui souhaitent recruter
des étrangers non communautaires de le
faire sans autorisation préalable pour
les métiers de tension c'est l'état du
droit la première ministre l'a rappelé
cette liste n'est plus adaptée les
métiers de la restauration ils sont très
peu présents tout comme ceux de la
propreté elle devra donc être demain
mise en phase avec la réalité car nous
connaissons tous dans cette des secteurs
à la fois les tensions de recrutement
mais aussi la proportion nettement plus
importante que la moyenne de recours à
des travailleurs étrangers
si nous devons regarder la réalité en
face pour ce qui concerne la part des
emplois en tension occupés aujourd'hui
par des travailleurs étrangers en
situation régulière ou irrégulière nous
devons aussi regarder notre réalité en
face c'est la faiblesse ou plutôt la
lenteur des sanctions infligées le
travail illégal est constaté est
délibéré or c'est une certitude la lutte
contre le travail légal passe par des
sanctions plus facilement plus
facilement applicables il existe
aujourd'hui des sanctions pénales que
nous ne prévoyons pas de modifier elles
sont nécessaires au traitement des
situations les plus graves dès lors que
l'intentionnalité et la dégradation des
conditions de travail sont manifestes il
existe aussi des sanctions
administratives comme la possibilité
pour les préfets de fermer
l'établissement pour une durée maximale
de trois mois il est certainement
opportun de les faciliter il nous faut
aussi une sanction administrative
calibrée pour être plus systématique
comme une amende la sanction n'aurait
pas un caractère automatique mais serait
déployé en fonction de l'appréciation
d'un certain nombre de critères tels que
les ressources et les charges
l'intentionnalité le contexte et la
gravité c'est cela que nous travaillons
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
apporter une réponse rapide
proportionnée efficace à ceux qui ont
recours délibérément intentionnellement
à des travailleurs en situation
irrégulière enfin j'en termine
l'intégration et c'est une évidence au
travail comme ailleurs se fait par la
langue en cohérence avec cette exigence
de maîtrise de la langue nous
considérons que les employeurs doivent
aussi faciliter l'intégration de leur
salarié étrangers par la langue bien
nombreux parmi eux comptent sur la main
d'oeuvre étrangère pour faire tourner
leurs entreprises il n'est donc pas
normal que les employeurs contribuent à
la réussite de l'intégration de leur
salarié par la formation continue par
éventuellement des abonnements à des
comptes personnels de formation ou
encore par le simple fait de libérer du
temps pour pouvoir participer aux
formations à l'apprentissage du français
nous abordons ce sujet de l'immigration
par le travail sans naïveté et surtout
en ne voulant plus et en ne voulant pas
être les complices passifs des
injustices existantes quand on travaille
des étrangers ni naïveté une idéalisme
mais du réalisme et la volonté de
protéger les travailleurs comme les
chefs d'entreprise n'ayant pas d'autres
alternatives après cette longue
présentation des axes de la future loi
sur l'immigration place au débat les
représentants des différents groupes
politiques représentés ce succède à la
tribune première oratrice Elsa faucillon
pour le groupe communiste
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
nous aurons donc dans quelques semaines
de longs débat sur l'immigration à la
défaveur d'un nouveau texte que nous
n'avons pas encore le 29e en 40 ans vous
avez monsieur le ministre Darmanin
présenté les premières lignes de ce
texte dans la presse et je dois vous
dire que plus vous en dites à son propos
plus nous craignons que les premières
annonces sur la possible régularisation
de travailleurs sans papier que nous
appelons de nos vœux soirée dites à
portion congrue et ce au profit de
mesures dont le seul appel d'air qu'elle
provoqueront sera celui des idées
d'extrême droite et je dois vous dire
quand vous entendez Jacques Bainville
dans votre intervention c'est plutôt de
mauvaise augure le débat d'aujourd'hui
il s'inscrit dans une période où
l'immigration est devenue un sujet
traité avec une grande irrationalité et
aussi beaucoup d'inhumanité aucun
chiffre n'atteste d'une submersion
migratoire d'ailleurs le sol de
migratoires est stable les grandes
phases de régularisation dans le passé
n'ont suscité aucun appel d'air et les
nombreuses et diverses études réalisées
démontrent combien les migrants
contribuent à la richesse du pays
d'accueil il ne menace ni l'emploi ni
les régimes de protection car ils sont
aussi des producteurs et des
productrices des contribuables des
cotisants et des créateurs et des
créatrices leur régularisation massive
entraînerait une élévation des normes
salariales pas l'inverse c'est peut-être
le problème d'ailleurs
répondre à un défi nécessite donc de
poser d'abord le bon diagnostic nous ne
traversons pas une crise migratoire mais
bien une crise de l'accueil et
particulièrement particulièrement quand
les personnes exilées viennent d'Afrique
du proche ou du Moyen-Orient le
contraste avec l'accueil nécessaire et
solidaire des Ukrainiens nous
interpellent
l'immigration c'est largement le produit
des incursions de pays européens dans
les pays du Sud ce qui migre réagissent
aussi au système mondial des inégalités
dont nous ne pouvons nous exempter tous
les murs dressés n'empêcheront pas ceux
qui n'ont que seul choix le départ de
partir
l'immigration c'est une partie de
l'histoire de notre monde elle est donc
profondément humaine elle exige de nous
de la responsabilité pas de s'envoyer la
balle à qui sera le plus ferme ou qui
sera la plus molle présenter ce sujet
comme un problème grandissant ou impose
ou un trait d'égalité entre immigration
et délinquance est un jeu dangereux qui
participe à légitimer une vision dont
l'histoire est profondément xénophobe
alors je sais il est bien pratique le
discours qui repose sur l'idée du trop
plein d'immigrés tant il permet un récit
alternatif au conséquences de choix
politiques dressés contre le peuple
contre le plus grand nombre alors quand
on s'annonce rempart on ne passe pas les
plats ce discours est dangereux aussi
pour celles et ceux qui arrivent sur
notre territoire comme pour notre
cohésion sociale quand on accorde en
permanence étrangers expulsion
délinquance et parfois même terroriste
terrorisme on met en danger notre
cohésion sociale car cela jette la
suspicion et le rejet
alors il va être beaucoup question d'OK
UTF visiblement c'est le cas d'à peu
près tous les textes sur l'immigration
ces dernières années il y a eu de
nombreuses propositions de multiples
croyez-vous vraiment que la 29ème y
parviendra sachant que l'obstacle majeur
c'est l'absence de laisser passer
conculaire et de titres de voyage non
mais pendant ce temps c'est le silence
autour de celles et ceux qui sont
abandonnés à l'enfer libyen pays
mandatés par l'Europe pour gérer nos
frontières régime qui prend l'argent
d'une main et monnaie des passages
mortels de l'autre silence sur les
refoulements et la corruption ont été
accusés Frontex silence autour du
sauvetage maritime abandonné à des
associations qui sont fondées par des
dons privés ou encore de la gestion de
la coordination des sauvetages qui a été
attribuée à la Libye dans un grand
silence le même qui règne lorsqu'elle
reçoit les appels de détresse en mer
nous ne pouvons pas d'une part dénoncer
la violence et l'instabilité de
certaines régions en crise et dans le
même printemps en nourrir la source
d'une main vendre des armes de l'autre
fléchez d'être public au développement
vers le renforcement des frontières
alors nous continuerons de vrai et de
tenter de convaincre que le monde de
demain oblige dès maintenant à préparer
un accueil digne cela passe par une
régularisation de celles et ceux qui
vivent ici qui travaillent ici et vous
le savez qu'il resteront ici et ce avec
un titre de séjour de plein droit la fin
aussi du pouvoir de l'employeur dans la
délivrance du titre de séjour par le
travail cela passe par un accueil digne
en préfecture un accès immédiat à la
protection universelle maladie un
investissement pour l'apprentissage du
français vous nous avez déjà fait le
coup de la fermeté et de l'humanité on
se demande tous les jours où est passé
l'humanité à part au fond de la mer
Méditerranée
dans l'hémicycle les orateurs de la
gauche réunis au sein de la nupesse
succède à la tribune pour dénoncer une
rhétorique mortifère un laisser mourir
en mer selon les termes de Mathilde
panot on va écouter la chef de fil des
insoumis suivi par l'écologie Benjamin
Lucas et par le socialiste Boris Vallaud
s'il est un sujet qui fait la part belle
aux effets de manche coup de menton
gesticulation exagérée bon bah je de
torsevin en face inutile fantasme variés
c'est sans aucun doute celui de la
politique de l'immigration depuis 40 ans
ce sujet obéit à un régime de parole
particulier la production de signes il
faut afficher fermeté dureté si bien que
vous êtes moins intéressé par ce que
vous dites que par l'effet supposé sur
votre auditoire depuis 40 ans la
fonction sociale de ce sujet est
exclusivement son instrumentalisation à
des fins politiques chacun y trouve son
compte Marine Le Pen à l'instant
sautille de joie à l'idée d'aborder
l'unique marqueur de sa petite boutique
de haine les LR raffolent de la
politique de l'immigration envisagé
comme le seul espace qu'il leur reste
pour se différencier de vous et
collectivement nous fournissons le décor
de votre entreprise de séduction de la
droite votre grille de lecture étriquée
du sujet guidé par la démagogie et celle
d'une imaginaire entre un prétendu
angélisme et l'inhumanité la plus classe
pourtant une autre voix est possible
nous sommes venus vous dire de revenir à
la raison
29 lois 29 lois depuis 1980 le
soi-disant tabou de l'immigration est en
réalité brisée au rythme d'une loi tous
les deux ans
pourquoi pourquoi ne jamais tirer de
bilan comment expliquer qu'un
gouvernement prétendument efficace
doivent s'y reprendre plus d'une fois
pour régler ce qu'il présente comme un
problème à moins de supposer que ces
lois ont finalement peu avoir avec
l'objet qu'elle traite il ne s'agit pas
de faire mais de montrer que l'on fait
en matière d'immigration mieux vaut une
démonstration de force une politique du
chiffre qu'une politique raisonnée la
temporalité n'est d'ailleurs jamais
innocente il y a toujours une raison
pour semer le poison de la discorde dans
le pays collègue les bonnes décisions
sont celles prises de sang-froid sur ce
sujet en particulier sont entretenus
sciemment les angoisses qui tétanisent
la réflexion avant toute chose il faut
faire acte de sa lubrité publique loin
des fantasmes d'une submersion
migratoire la France est l'un des pays
d'Europe de l'Ouest où l'immigration est
parmi les plus faibles la plupart des
migrations se fait en réalité entre les
pays du Sud
contrairement à vos élucubrations
xénophobes personne ne résume ne compare
les régimes sociaux européens avant de
venir en France comme le font en
revanche vos milliardaires lorsqu'ils
hésitent entre la Suisse et les îles
Fidji pour choisir le régime fiscal le
plus avantageux
l'aide médicale d'État sur lequel vous
êtes si prolixe ne représente que 0,5 %
des dépenses de santé prise en charge
par l'Assurance Maladie les personnes
immigrées rencontrent surtout un
problème de non recours à ce droit et un
important renoncement aux soins
collègues revenait donc à la raison les
déplacements de population sont une
réalité historique vous ne construirez
jamais de Mûrs assez grand pour vous
protéger de l'aspiration de chaque être
humain à une vie meilleure
il faut donc permettre à chacun de vivre
dignement là où il est mais cela exige
de faire cesser une certaine hypocrisie
car ceux qui stigmatisent les immigrés
sont les mêmes qui soutiennent les
politiques libérales dévastatrices pour
les pays du Sud les mêmes qui promènent
des accords de libre-échange quand ce ne
sont pas des guerres le capitalisme
néo-libéral n'a d'autres vocations que
d'épuiser les ressources et les êtres
humains et de rendre le monde
fondamentalement inhabitable
oui collègues votre hypocrisie vous fait
trébucher d'une bêtise à l'autre vous
êtes des hypocrites quand vous tolérez
sans mal la législation sur les
travailleurs détachés mettant en
concurrence des travailleurs européens
dans une course effrénée vers le moins
disant social hypocrite quand vous
serrez la vis des politiques
d'immigration rendant la vie de
centaines de milliers de gens
impossibles pourtant bienheureux quand
les mêmes contribuent à tenir notre pays
debout pendant la crise sanitaire
hypocrite quand vous parlez sans cesse
de la valeur travail comme d'un facteur
d’intégration et refusé que les
demandeurs d'asile exerce un emploi
pendant le délai d'examen de leur
dossier hypocrite quand l'État lui-même
fabrique des sans-papiers par une
dématérialisation inhumaine pas de
rendez-vous en préfecture pas de
renouvellement de titre pas de
renouvellement plein d'emploi et parfois
plus de logement hypocrite car vous
entretenez la délocalisation sur place
des secteurs entiers de l'économie du
BTP à la restauration en passant par les
services à la personne repose sur cette
main d'oeuvre bon marché condamné à la
SERV par la menace qui pèse constamment
sur leur tête l'expulsion hypocrisie
ultime lorsqu'en plus de fabriquer des
personnes sans papiers vous les
exploitez je salue les travailleurs
sous-traitants de la Poste présent ici
en tribune depuis un an ils tiennent
trois piquets de grève devant
chronopostal Forville DPD à coudrey
Monceau et encore récemment devant RSI à
Gennevilliers vous savez que la Poste
entreprise à capital public emploie des
personnes sans papiers corvéables à
merci temps partiel imposé par des
salaires de misère embauche à trois ou
quatre heures du matin pas de paiement
d'heure supplémentaire pas d'arrêt
maladie ni de pause réglementaires vous
le savez qu'avez-vous à leur dire
vous préférez laisser l'impunité
patronale perdurer
hypocrite enfin quand certains parlent
ici de retourner en Afrique et font
travailler des personnes sans papiers
dans leur vigne comme Monsieur de
Fournas
ayez au moins les atouts de la cohérence
mettez un terme au régime des
travailleurs détachés et régulariser
tous les travailleurs sans papiers
collègues l'immigration est un phénomène
qui connaîtra des changements d'échelle
les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique conduiront un milliard de
personnes sur les routes de l'exil dans
ces circonstances il nous faut choisir
le chaos ou l'entraide dès aujourd'hui
l'urgence climatique exige qu'une aide
financière et matérielle à la
bifurcation écologique soit attribuée au
pays les plus vulnérables fondés sur les
transferts de savoir et par la
reconnaissance d'un statut de détresse
environnementale la seule réponse
raisonnable et d'organiser la solidarité
en vue du plus grand défi que l'humanité
aura à connaître il nous faut donc de
réelles politiques publiques pour
organiser l'accueil pour cela la
philosophie m'a en partage depuis des
siècles un principe qui nous est
précieux agir de telle sorte que la
maxime de notre action puisse être
érigée en loi universelle personne
collègue ni responsable de sa naissance
dans la misère dans un pays pauvre en
guerre ou un pays en première ligne face
aux dérèglement climatiques
ayez donc le courage de traiter ces
personnes avec dignité renforcer les
structures d'accueil d'hébergement dites
à Monsieur Darmanin de cesser la
criminalisation outrancière des
associations qui donnent juste à
beauhari à manger aux exilés à Calais
abolissez l'infâme délit de solidarité
mettez un terme à l'enfermement des
enfants dans les centres de rétention
interdisaient enfin les tests osseux
cesser pour finir votre chasse sur les
terres de l'extrême droite alors nous
parlons 342 jeunes dorment devant le
Conseil d'État après avoir passé 6 mois
à la rue ils veulent aller à l'école
mais Monsieur le Ministre Darmanin est
trop occupé à montrer les muscles les
politiques d'immigration ne peuvent
pourtant être réduites au Giron
sécuritaire elles doivent inclure la
santé l'éducation la culture la lutte
contre les dixcriminations et être
articulé sur le long terme et avant
toute chose madame la Première ministre
il faut que tout le monde dans ce pays
puisse vivre dignement lorsque vous
détruisez les services publics ce sont
les personne les plus pauvres que Vous
sanctionnez en priorité et parmi elles
les derniers arrivés en France vous ne
parviendrez pas à faire diversion en ce
qui concerne les conditions matérielles
d'existence du peuple la colère qui
gronde ne sera jamais dissipée avec des
lois pointant des boucs émissaires vous
voulez rétablir l'ordre abandonnez votre
réforme des retraites bloquez les prix
augmenter les salaires et partager les
richesses
pour le reste collègue
la France a pour promesse liberté
égalité fraternité chacun un peu en
faire le serment c'est le propre d'une
nation universaliste
j'achève avec ces mots
nous sommes dans l'eau aidez-nous s'il
vous plaît nous sommes en train de
mourir nous sommes dans la mer dedans il
fait froid
ce sont les derniers mots prononcés par
l'une des 27 personnes exilées mortes
dans une traversée de la Manche en 2021
parmi elles une petite fille de 7 ans
il leur a été répandu oui mais vous êtes
dans les eaux anglaises collègues
j'arrête il serait erroné de ne voir
dans cette réponse qu'une faute
individuelle sans percevoir la longue
entreprise collective de
déshuminalisation raciste qui l'a rendu
possible tant de paroles ont alimenté
ces dernières années ce processus au
terme duquel certaines vies ne valent
pas la peine d'être sauvées et
certainement d'être pleurer cette
tragédie est l'aboutissement de
politique dont le paradigme est toujours
la sévérité contre tout soupçon de
laxisme nous savons au fond quel est le
point culminant de cette rhétorique
mortifère le laisser mourir en mer
nous sommes ni dans l'obsession ni dans
l'aveuglement ni déni face au défi de
l'immigration ni postures viril et en
définitive veine qui finissent par
désespérer les Français nous savons que
sans être au sommet de leur
préoccupation et de leur difficulté
quotidiennes la question migratoire Tao
de les Françaises et les Français dans
un moment d'angoisse existentielle et
même culturel tente a beaucoup l'avenir
est incertain le présent difficile
l'idéal d'intégration malmenée disons-le
aussi nettement de défiance à l'égard de
la politique nous leur devons un débat
honnête et juste qui nous autorise en
inkipit et en loint Eco à Jean-Pierre
chevenant il y a 25 ans a rappelé que
parler des étrangers c'est aussi une
autre manière de parler de la France oui
de parler de la France et des Français
de rappeler que le peuple français ne
s'est jamais défini par la souche mais
par le bonheur d'être ensemble en
donnant sens à son histoire et
j'ajouterai par la grande et belle
ambition de construire ensemble une
nation d'ego la France marche au mélange
elle est le creuset fertile duquel
jaillit le meilleur les visages des
premiers de corvées qui se sont révélés
dans la crise les visages de celles et
de ceux
issus de tous les pays qui portent hauts
et de bien des manières les couleurs de
notre pays je dis à nos compatriotes
français dont les aïeux furent un moment
de leur histoire personnelle des
étrangers je leur dis cette évidence qui
me fait mal de devoir appeler parce que
d'autres la comtesse sur ses bancs vous
êtes français on peut aimer la France et
la terre de ses ancêtres peut-être
est-ce même là le cœur de
l'universalisme républicain comme le
disait Aimé Césaire l'universel riche de
tout le particulier riche de tous les
particuliers
c'est par une politique d'asile et
d'immigration respectueuse des droits
des étrangers par des règles claires des
procédures efficaces par les dignités de
l'accueil par le respect de l'ordre
public et social par une politique
volontariste d'intégration que viendra
la régulation et la maîtrise des flux
migratoires attendues par les Français
les murs administratifs que vous avez
dressé n'arrêtent rien ils enferment
dans des situations de non-droits et
dans des accueils indignes remettez
d'abord de l'ordre dans le désordre
actuel voilà ce qu'attendent les
Français ayant de l'ambition et de
l'humanité comme nos voisins allemands
ont été capables de le faire accueillant
un million de réfugiés il disait nous y
arriverons
vous n'aimez pas la France vous n'aimez
pas la France parce que vous la voyez
faible incapable de rayonner de se
transformer vous n'aimez pas son
histoire faite de mélange et de
dépassement nous nous croyons que l'on
peut faire France de tout bois parce que
c'est notre histoire notre richesse
notre génie même que de fabriquer sans
cesse une culture nourrie par d'autres
ne soyons pas une nation frileuse
repliée sur elle-même comme si elle
n'avait pas su trouver dans son histoire
la force de se renouveler de se
réinventer de se régénérer et donc de se
renforcer
[Applaudissements]
oui nous croyons qu'une France généreuse
accueillante fraternelle est une France
plus forte face aux urgences du présent
et au grand défi de l'avenir
chers collègues la France et le plus
ancien pays d'immigration en Europe
c'est notre tradition depuis le 18e
siècle aujourd'hui elle n'est que le
cinquième pays européen par le nombre de
ces étrangers où est donc votre
submersion migratoire avoir confiance
c'est régulariser ceux qui travaillent
cotisent payent des impôts avoir
confiance c'est attiré ici des milliers
d'étudiants qui construisent un lien
intellectuel scientifique technique
durable avec notre pays avoir confiance
ces chérir la générosité et la
fraternité en mettant fin au harcèlement
des humanitaires et aux délits de
solidarité
avoir confiance c'est garantir l'accès
aux droits pour tous les exilés avoir
confiance ces dispenser à chacune et à
chacun les soins physiques et
psychologiques nécessaires
avoir confiance c'est refuser que les
groupes musculent remettent en cause la
liberté pédagogique fondement de l'école
républicaine et menace avec violence une
enseignante qui explique et montre à ses
étudiants la réalité des migrations
avoir confiance c'est sortir ce débat
sur l'immigration de la pression
électoraliste des pulsions des
surenchères plusieurs associations
proposent une convention citoyenne sur
les migrations voilà qui sortiraient de
la répétition compulsive des textes et
des vociférations stériles
avoir confiance c'est construire une
grande politique de l'inclusion qui
brise les plafonds de verre qui Combal
le racisme et les discriminations qui
refusent la signation à résidence le
chômage la précarité en confiance et en
vérité débarrasser des peurs et des
mensonges faisant vivre la fraternité
au sein de la majorité on salue le bon
équilibre trouvé entre intégration et
expulsion la présidente du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale
Aurore Bergé renvoie dosados ceux qui
veulent faire de l'Europe une forteresse
et ceux qui font preuve selon elle de
laxisme en matière de politique
migratoire écoutez Aurore berger suivi
par Elodie Jacquier Laforge du groupe
démocrate puis Laurent Marc Angeli chef
de fil des députés horizons extrait de
séance le 9 janvier 2015 lors de la
prise d'otages à l'hypercacher de la
Porte de Vincennes à Paris un jeune
travailleur malien Lassana Bathily a
contribué à sauver plusieurs Français
juifs pris en otage par un djihadiste
par ce geste cet homme a fait son devoir
d'humanité et c'est toute la République
qui lui a rendu hommage aujourd'hui il a
reçu son décret de naturalisation il est
français
le 9 août 2021 un étranger fauche avec
toute l'atrocité des bases instincts le
Père Olivier maire cette fois-ci c'est
le sentiment inverse qui nous accable
comment expliquer qu'un homme entrer
illégalement sur notre sol en 2012
puisque mettre l'irréparable au moment
même où libérer sous contrôle judiciaire
après l'incendie de la cathédrale de
Nantes il n'est lui-même plus expulsable
ces deux exemples nous inspirent au fond
de réactions contraires qui sont les
deux faces d'une même caricature côté
pile il y a ceux qui semblent douter de
tout du haut de leur forteresse qui
ressemblerait plus à une ligne Maginot
l'étranger est présumé délinquant et la
République qui traite dès lors pour de
bons l'humanité l'immigration de e0
n'existe pas et heureusement
côté face il y a ceux qui semblent ne
douter de rien la France serait la
planche de salut du monde moderne fort
heureusement ces projets accueillent
plus qu'il intègrent au point que large
de Noé se dispute souvent au radeau de
la Méduse côté pile c'est donc le verre
à moitié vide de la grandeur de Rome ils
n'ont retenu que le déclin et à leur
phobie et leur phobie tient en deux
apostrophes l'appel d'air côté face
c'est le verre à moitié plein leur
politique commence souvent par accueil
mais finit rarement par expulsion leur
fantasmes c'est un pays all inclusive au
fond la noblesse d'âme des uns répond à
la disposition d'esprit des autres
sans jamais pointer du doigt le paradoxe
que révèle ses files d'attente des
armées numériques plus souterraines
devant les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures pour la délivrance de
titre de séjour le paradoxe donc d'un
système inhumain qui fait subir à des
étrangers en situation régulière le
chemin de croix d'un renouvellement le
paradoxe d'un système inefficace ou la
lourdeur de la politique de guichet
rallonge d'autant plus l'exécution de la
politique d'éloignement après une
probable protestation devant le juge
voyons les choses en face avec lucidité
nos règles européennes et nationales
sont devenus inadaptées nos procédures
sont longues les voies de recours sont
multiples en parallèle nous vous avons
un système d'aide monétaire social
médical bien plus élaboré que tous nos
voisins ce système est donc doublement
inefficace d'abord car toute personne de
mauvaise foi qui demande un titre de
séjour dans notre pays dispose d'une
latitude d'action pour s'enfermer dans
une manœuvre dilatoire et détourner le
système à son avantage ensuite car toute
personne vertueuse sans intention
d'essouffler le système peut se perdre
dans le maquis de notre enfer procédural
il faut donc remettre à plat notre droit
et garantir ce faisant celui des
étrangers nous voulons que l'hypogrisie
cesse pour que ces trappes à illégalité
disparaissent il faut des mesures pour
que les travailleurs étrangers eux-mêmes
afin de faciliter leur accès au travail
dans des situations bien définies et
déterminées et des mesures envers les
employeurs afin qu'ils participent mieux
à l'intégration sociale de leur salarié
cela passe entre autres par des mesures
de régulation je pense notamment au
secteur des plateformes de transport et
de et de livraison par des réponses
adaptées aux métiers en tension aux
besoins des entreprises en matière de
profil très qualifiés et si nécessaire
par des sanctions dissuasives et
appliquées en cas d'emploi d'un étranger
clandestin
né en 2005 le CZ le code de l'entrée et
du séjour des étrangers et du droit
d'asile peut-être le code le plus épais
de notre droit a connu de nombreux
toilettages depuis la fin des années 80
l'immigration a connu 21 lois 21 lois en
32 ans c'est certainement trop
reconnaissons le il existe très peu de
domaines dans lesquels on les GIF faire
autant
cela doit nous conduire à l'humilité je
crois quelle que soit notre place dans
l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre vous entendez
aujourd'hui ouvrir une nouvelle page
vous avez choisi de mener plusieurs
chantiers renforcer notre efficacité
pour lutter contre les menaces à l'ordre
public et à l'immigration irrégulière
nous nous réjouissons que la lutte
contre les passeurs qui exploite la
détresse humaine en face partie engager
une réforme structurelle de notre
système d'asile en effet le traitement
des demandes d'asile est encore beaucoup
trop long et source d'un trop grand
contentieux sur ce point il est
important que les collectivités locales
soient des partenaires actifs et de
relais sans lequel les représentants de
sur lesquels les représentants de l'État
devront s'appuyer car sans l'échelle
locale rien ne se fera cependant il
faudra être attentif pour les OCC à ne
pas déséquilibrer le système en voulant
aller trop vite sans respecter les
droits du recours en appel d'une
décision
vous entendez également renforcer les
exigences d'intégration par la langue et
le travail nous en sommes satisfaits je
le disais tout à l'heure il ne peut y
avoir d'intégration sans maîtrise de la
langue et un accès au travail surtout
ces sujets nous aurons le temps de
travailler ensemble pour arriver à
l'équilibre et à l'efficacité le temps
est venu d'être réaliste d'être
pragmatique oui nous avons besoin
d'immigration mais celle-ci ne saurait
conduire à un délitement de nos valeurs
non elle ne saurait conduire à
s'éloigner de l'idée que nous faisons de
la France du respect et de la défense de
nos valeurs fondamentales celles qui
structure notre pays les valeurs de la
République
malgré des plus de 20 lois votées dans
cette hémicycle depuis 1986 nous voici
une nouvelle fois à débattre de ce sujet
qui pour des raisons à la fois
idéologiques mais aussi souvent intime
nous anime chacun profondément et
conduisent malheureusement certains se
muraient dans des postures regrettables
pour que chacun tente de sortir de ses
postures commençons par nous accorder
sur un diagnostic notre pays compte
aujourd'hui 10,3% d'immigrés soit 7
millions de personnes la dynamique
constatée s'agissant du solde migratoire
se confirme avec en moyenne 200 000
immigrés supplémentaires chaque année
dans notre pays
pour l'Europe la question migratoire est
donc avant tout une question de
résilience de long terme elle ne saurait
se poser sans tenir compte de la
conjoncture géopolitique dans la
prévisibilité est extrêmement variable
qu'il s'agisse de guerre de crise
économique et bientôt des effets des
changements climatiques
l'Afrique comptera selon certaines
projections 4 milliards d'habitants en
2100 contre 650 millions en Europe avec
une population plus jeune qu'ici
face à ce vertige démographique notre
système actuel européen et national et
trop fragile et il doit être adapté pour
préserver demain la cohésion nationale
sur les bancs de la droite on a de
grandes réserves contre les mesures
envisagées par le gouvernement orateur
pour son groupe le député les
républicains Pierre-Henri Dumont accuse
le gouvernement de vouloir régulariser
massivement les clandestins et l'appel à
clarifier ses intentions madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues fiasco faillite des
bandas d'échecs les mots pour décrire
les résultats de la stratégie migratoire
menée depuis 5 ans par le Président de
la République et ses affidés successifs
ne manquent pas contrairement à votre
courage politique qui lui fait gravement
défaut record historique de titres de
séjour délivrés records historiques de
demande de demandeurs d'asile record
historique d'inexécution d'obligation de
quitter le territoire français record
historique de CLAND record historique du
coût de l'aide médicale d'État record
historique d'étrangers en prison vous
avez madame la Première ministre réussi
le Grand Chelem de l'inertie
administrative de l'incurie migratoire
et de l'abandon de la France en matière
d'immigration il ne peut pas y avoir de
en même temps où vous voulez plus
d'immigrations vous voulez moins
d'immigration dans notre pays où vous
dites qu'il y a un lien entre
immigration et délinquance comme le
ministre de l'intérieur où vous dites
qu'il n'y a pas de lien comme vous
l'avez dit où vous accueillez le chien
de Viking où vous voulez plus expulser
il n'y a pas d'entre-deux vous
gouvernement député de la majorité de
gauche et d'extrême gauche vous voulez
plus d'immigrations en France nous
députés les républicains nous voulons
moins d'immigration en France votre en
même temps migratoire votre volonté de
ne froisser personne et en particulier
vos amis de l'intelligensia boboïse vous
conduit à délacheter successives au
détriment de ceux qui souffrent
concrètement quotidiennement d'une
immigration incontrôlé et non intégré
les députés indépendants et ultramarins
réunis au sein du groupe lyaute appelle
eux à la vigilance il réclame une
politique de l'immigration juste et
humaine la parole est à Bertrand pencher
pour 5 minutes
parmi vos objectifs madame la Première
ministre figure une simplification une
rationalisation du contentieux du droit
des étrangers nous partageons l'objectif
en vous alertant néanmoins sur les
moyens proposés pour y parvenir il n'est
pas question évidemment de réduire les
droits de l'homme les droits
fondamentaux des migrants ainsi l'idée
de généraliser le juge unique de la CNDA
ne nous semble pas aller dans le bon
sens car remettre entre les mains d'une
seule et même personne l'instruction des
recours c'est se priver de nombreux
expertises donc celle du CHR
si nous construisons un accueil plus
digne et plus efficace il nous semble
opportun en contrepartie d'augmenter nos
exigences vis-à-vis des étrangers que
nous accueillons ainsi le renforcement
des capacités d'expulsion de ce
trou-plan gravement l'ordre public et
notamment l'idée de limiter les
protections relatives et quasi absolue
les étrangers dit protégés ça donnant à
des troubles graves nous semblent
raisonnables une bonne politique
d'immigration c'est aussi une bonne
politique d'intégration qui s'est donné
un avenir à ceux qu'elle décide
d'accueillir les simplifications
évoquées pour la future loi nous semble
opportunes en particulier la
simplification de la procédure de
l'autorisation de travail et le
renforcement des dispositifs tels celui
des passeports talents c'est une bonne
idée de créer un nouveau titre de séjour
concernant les métiers sous tension on
en a tant besoin sur le plan du travail
et nous voulons nous aussi des garanties
nous souhaitons que la liste de le
métier prenne réellement en compte les
besoins en fonction des territoires et
ne laisse pas de côté faute de mise à
jour régulières un certain nombre de
travailleurs autre sujet d'inquiétude
qu'adviendra-t-il des personnes qui dans
ce cadre perdront leur emploi c'est
hydro de séjour professionnel étant
particulièrement précaire il faut avoir
l'assurance qu'une perte d'emploi
n'introduira pas une perte du droit au
séjour une politique d'immigration digne
de ce nom c'est celle qui nous
permettrait un retour à l'accès immédiat
également aux soins des demandeurs
d'asile comme avant la mise en place des
trois mois de carence institués en 2019
afin que leur état de santé n'est pas le
temps de se dégrader comme cela arrive
trop souvent aujourd'hui ce qui est
finalement contre-productif y compris
évidemment pour notre système de santé
une politique d'immigration digne de ce
nom c'est aussi celle et ceux qui ne
détournent pas le regard face aux
migrants sans papiers qui fois depuis
des années travail de manière non
déclarée sur notre territoire et qui
font tout pour s'intégrer on sait
pertinemment pour des tas de raisons
qu'ils ne pourront jamais être expulsés
tout le monde le sait s'acharner à ne
pas leur donner des papiers c'est les
condamnés à rester au bord de notre
société à basculer dans la pauvreté à
dormir dans nos rues et à verser des
larmes de crocodiles quand nous passons
devant des tentes de migrants qui
croupissent dans des conditions sordides
nuitées jour y compris l'hiver dans les
rues de Paris à ce jeu malsain tout le
monde y perd son âme et sa dignité
puisque la plupart d'entre-travail notre
société a besoin de leurs bras madame la
Première ministre et j'en finis là tout
est question d'équilibre nous resterons
particulièrement vigilants sur la
finalisation de votre projet de loi car
nous souhaitons que ce texte permettent
une politique de l'immigration dans
notre pays enfin efficace parce que
courageuse juste et humaine
côté rassemblement national Marine Le
Pen évoque un texte qui ne sert à rien
un texte placebo elle réclame une vraie
loi sur l'immigration rappelant son
projet de référendum pendant la campagne
présidentielle
la question de l'immigration est un
océan de mensonges de manipulation de
non-dits et de culpabilisation
permanente
mensonge et manipulation quand après
nous avons expliqué faussement que
l'immigration était arrêtée depuis 1974
les campagnes de propagande d'État ont
professé quelle était une chance pour la
France aujourd'hui tout est fait pour
l'invisibilité pour faire croire qu'elle
n'existerait pas ou pire qu'elle serait
inéluctable non dit et culpabilisation
quand les pouvoirs publics s'incenis à
manipuler le nombre de clandestins en
recourant à des régularisations
incessantes celui des étrangers par des
naturalisations massives agnez le poids
écrasant de l'immigration dans
l'explosion de l'insécurité
dans le même temps on refuse d'évaluer
le nombre d'illégaux présents sur le
territoire on refuse d'estimer l'impact
social de l'immigration ou en déterminer
le coût total la vérité c'est que les
immigrationnistes sont conscients que
les peuples attachés à leur culture et à
leur mode de vie ces peuples qui ont
encore un instinct de vie ou de survie
qui ont combattu durant des siècles pour
leur liberté et leur valeur ne veulent
pas de cette submersion
pour les dirigeants français ou
européens
habité par une vision globalisme qui
chaque jour se fracasse sur la
recomposition du monde l'immigration
n'est pas un problème mais un projet un
projet qu'il faut imposer au peuple par
le mensonge par parfois par l'omission
par la manipulation et par la politique
du fait accompli permettez-moi une
confidence je préfère encore des
immigrationnistes assumées comme nos
collègues de la France insoumise et leur
projet faussement humaniste mais sans
équivoque de créolisation aux
immigrationnistes honteux qui peuplent
la vie politique depuis 40 ans c'est
partisans
du laisser-aller et du laisser passer
qui s'abrite derrière des discours
prétendument ferme pour laisser se
poursuivre en Souma la submersion de nos
pays qui s'abrite derrière des motifs
pseudo-humanitaires pour laisser se
dérouler devant nos yeux un gigantesque
trafic d'être humain vous l'avez compris
et compris depuis longtemps ceci n'est
pas notre projet nous croyons aux
nations et au peuple nous croyons que
les hommes sont des êtres qui se
définissent par des filiation et des
affiliations des allégeances et des
interdépendances des histoires
personnelles et collectives qui font
deux des êtres d'affection familiale
d'appartenance culturelle d'attachement
national
ils ne sont pas comme vous le professeur
des aniware selon la formule de David
good art des nomades destinées à errer
dans un monde indifférencié des
créatures interchangeables ils ne
peuvent résumer leur vie à des actes
reproduction et de consommation il n'est
de pire faute morale que de déraciner
quelqu'un de le priver de son histoire
de sa mémoire ou de sa terre c'est
pourquoi nous pensons que l'émigration
est la dernière des solutions cela
signifie que le monde est pas seulement
l'Europe doit s'engager dans une
politique d'aide au développement des
pays pauvres une aide au développement
qui profite réellement à leurs habitants
et non à leurs dirigeants corrompus cela
signifie que la question des réfugiés
doit être traitée régionalement dans le
cadre de cité azilia des cités d'accueil
installé au pourtour des zones en crise
nous devons cesser d'admettre ces
détournements du droit d'asile qui en
ruine la pertinence juridique et parce
que le message doit être celui de la
fermeté les régularisations doivent être
prohibées le droit de vivre selon nos
lois et nos coutumes selon nos rites et
nos modes de vie que nous reconnaissons
au peuple du monde nous le revendiquons
pour nous
tout comme nous revendiquons le droit à
la continuité historique le droit de
vivre conformément à nos valeurs de
civilisation conformément à notre
conception de la vie et de l'homme c'est
pourquoi nous réclamons une grande loi
de régulation de l'immigration à l'image
de ce qui se fait au Danemark d'après
les premiers éléments que nous avons il
apparaît que nous ne te retrouverons
rien de cela dans votre projet futur
projet de loi c'est un énième texte
placebo qui n'a pour objet que de tenter
de faire croire aux citoyens distraits
que vous agissez alors que la situation
migratoire est plus que jamais hors de
contrôle un texte qui loin de réguler le
flux migratoire ouvre avec le prétexte
des métiers en tension de nouvelles
voies d'entrée frauduleuses ou des
régularisations massives tout cela se
faisant à la demande d'un patrona sans
scrupule toujours avec le même argument
les Français seraient un peuple de
feignants et de réfractaires alors que
c'est votre immigrationnisme qui porte
en lui-même le déclassement les salaires
bas et l'affaissement dramatique de la
productivité des emplois
nous nous refusons de voir ainsi le
trafic des hommes légalisés nous
refusons de voir d'autres pays submergé
quand dans le même tentant de jeunes
Français se sent obligés de quitter
notre pays les Français sont très
majoritaires à penser que l'immigration
doit cesser ils sont également très
majorités à penser que ce gouvernement
est incapable de juguler ce fléau j'ai
proposé durant la dernière campagne
présidentielle un projet de référendum
sur cette question il est urgent
nécessaire et surtout démocratique que
le peuple français puisse enfin se
prononcer sur cette question
fondamentale
après plus de 3h30 de débat sur
l'immigration le gouvernement vient
clore la séance la parole est à Gérald
Darmanin suivi par Elisabeth borne
monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et les outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci la présidente peut-être quelques
mots de réponse à mon tour aux orateurs
peut-être à Monsieur Vallot il n'est pas
là mais de là où il est de nous entendre
lui dire que peut-être sur la question
un peu dure sur pourquoi ça marche pas
dans la préfecture j'aurais aimé qu'il
puisse faire son son propre mais à culpa
puisque c'est bien sous le gouvernement
de François Hollande qu'on a supprimé
une très grande partie des agents de
préfecture que l'un derrière la cour de
comptes et c'est nous qui réparons
désormais ce drame en remettant des
agents de préfecture qui peuvent
justement bien accueillir les étrangers
donc je crois que là quand on chante la
vérité on la chante pas à moitié
camarade ce serait une bonne chose à mon
avis de de dire ce qu'il a dit
d'ailleurs en incipit de son
intervention qu'il faut avoir un
discours simple honnête et en plus de
vérité je crois que oui je crois que on
lui fera le passager mais à part cela on
pouvait être d'accord sur une partie de
ces de ces propositions
sur la question des immigrés clandestins
ça a été dit par beaucoup de gens ici et
notamment par le rassemblement national
bien sûr mais aussi par les républicains
je veux juste dire de mots à Madame
Genval et à Monsieur Dumont en 2004 il y
a eu 105 y avait 151000 étrangers en
situation régulière au sens où ils
étaient inscrits à ce qu'on appelle la
me qui est le meilleur moyen sans doute
je cite Patrick Stéphanie de voir
combien d'étrangins se sont annuaire il
y a sur le sol national en 2017 donc
deux quinquennat passées il y en a eu
315000 on est passé de 151000 à
315000 étrangins se sont agréés en deux
quinquennats avec une même progression
d'ailleurs à peu près ce de quelqu'un là
une petite accélération sur Monsieur
Hollande enfin c'était quand même le
vrai évidemment sous le quinquennat du
président Sarkozy pour plein de raisons
d'ailleurs pour des raisons de
difficultés du monde que nous comprenons
tout à fait un peu déjà les réfugiés
climatiques parfois la démographie ce
qui a été évoquée mais aussi par un tas
de qui était déstabilisé a commencé par
la Libye bien évidemment et puis sous le
président Macron on est passé 315000 à
360 000 c'est vrai que ça augmente mais
ça augmente si vous faites le calcul 8
fois moins que sur les deux quinquennat
précédent et quand vous nous reprochez
après de vouloir régulariser ce terme
faut mais on aura le débat parlementaire
pour le dire des personnes qui sont
depuis cinq ans sur le territoire
national qui travaille pardon même jeune
homme mais nous régularisons des
personnes qui sont rentrées sous les
quinquennats précédents pas pour ceux
qui sont arrivés il y a trois oui il y a
4 ans puisque ne serait-ce que la
circulaire valse c'est 5 ans
d'ancienneté sur le territoire national
et on fait 30 000 régularisations par an
donc oui on régularise c'est vrai mais
on le fait pour tous ceux qui sont
rentrés voilà déjà plus de 10 ans sur le
territoire national et vous le savez
très bien et je pense que si on veut un
débat il y a moins de monde dans
l'hémicycle désormais plus personne ou
moins de monde nous écoute mais si on
veut un débat sincère et serein il faut
qu'on dise aussi la vérité des prix et
la vérité des prix c'est que par
ailleurs sous le quinquennat du
président Macron le Soudan l'Afghanistan
la ça a été des pays qui se sont
rajoutés aux difficultés des demandes
d'asile par exemple et je crois que
c'est pas très honnête la façon dont
vous avez présenté les choses et je peux
me permettre un jeune Var on aura
l'occasion sans doute de reparler dans
le débat mais en tout cas la comparaison
est prêt on est prêt à comparer toutes
les comparaisons je pense qu'elle ne
sont pas très favorables au test que
vous défendez sur la question des
aucutés f là aussi entre 2007 et 2012
le nombre de qtf qui ont été mis c'était
60 000
et les exécutés c'était 12000 c'est à
dire que sous le quinquennat du
président Sarkozy on exécutait 19% des
qtf nous nous sommes à 15% des occultés
F exécutés pour la période 2017-2022
sachant qu'on a eu deux années où il y a
pas de transport aérien où il y avait le
covid donc c'est pas facile d'expulser
ces personnes quand on est entre 15 et
19%, je pense qu'il y a pas de leçon de
morale à donner je crois à cette tribune
je pense que vous n'avez pas plus
expulsé nous n'avons pas plus expulsé à
l'époque que maintenant pour des tas de
raisons très compliquées qu'on pourrait
d'ailleurs améliorer mais je pense que
ce serait mentir je crois aux électeurs
et aux habitants de dire que il y a 5
ans il y a 10 ans on savait expulser que
depuis président Macron on sait pas le
faire oui donc vous êtes exactement dans
un pourcentage que nous étions madame
genvar et je pense qu'il faut regarder
en plus la vérité en face il y avait
l'époque même des départs aidés vous le
savez très bien de gens qui étaient
payés et qui revenaient trois mois après
avec le pécule vous avez arrêté ça sous
la fin du quinquennat donc mais c'est
pas très il faut qu'on le compare et il
faut voir qu'est-ce qu'il doit changer
fondamentalement et c'est ce que nous
proposons d'ailleurs dans le texte de
loi que qu'on vous présentera vous dites
on attend de voir ce texte de loi mais
les débats présentés par la première
ministre ici au Sénat sont des débats
qui ne sont pas pour rien puisque nous
n'avons pas encore transmis nos
écritures au Conseil d'État nous
attendons la fin des débats et des
consultations d'ailleurs je crois que
nous voyons bientôt votre groupe
politique la semaine prochaine me
semble-t-il à Bobo avec le ministre du
Travail et on écoutera évidemment toutes
les propositions
je voudrais dire et Madame la premier
c'était que l'essentiel des propositions
que nous mettons sur la partie de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière de non
régularisation justement des personnes
qui sont sans titre de séjour de retour
dans les pays d'origine viennent du
rapport buffet nous avons fait je veux
réussir les coupables mais il y a pas
droit d'auteur nous avons fait un
copier-coller du rapport buffet pour une
très grande partie de disposition donc
non ce n'est pas vrai il en est d'accord
il en est d'accord d'ailleurs on
écoutera avec l'intérêt président buffet
au Sénat puisque nous arrivons toujours
à travailler je crois de bonne
intelligence avec le CA soient ces
questions encore une fois je pense que
la comparaison
pas elle est pas elle n'est pas
l'avantage je voulais tout d'abord
remercier les oratrices les orateurs et
les parlementaires présents aujourd'hui
son surprise malheureusement nous avons
entendu plusieurs interventions de pure
postures de pure démagogie et parfois de
purement songe sans aucune proposition
en particulier du côté du rassemblement
national qui a pu reprendre au mot près
les discours qui ont une bonne
cinquantaine d'années et je ne relève
pas non plus que le discours de la
présidente panneau parle d'un projet qui
n'est pas celui du gouvernement elle
lance des saillies sur des sujets que
j'ai précisément écarté j'en viens à
croire que les insoumis voudraient
vraiment s'en tenir à un tête-à-tête
avec le rassemblement national en lui
parlant comme s'il était au gouvernement
je ne vais donc pas m'attarder plus
longtemps les ministres ont eu
l'occasion de mettre en lumière les
contradictions les contreérités que
contenait certaines interventions je ne
vais pas alimenter des débats qui se
fonde sur des peurs et non pas sur la
réalité des débats qui se font sur des
polémiques et non pas sur des solutions
en revanche j'ai entendu et c'est ce que
je veux retenir parmi les groupes de
l'arc républicains des constats communs
et des propositions utiles
au-delà des clivages nous partageons une
volonté d'agir directement sur les
causes de l'immigration illégale en
accompagnant les pays de départ et de
transit en mettant notre aide au
développement au service de la lutte
contre la pauvreté et le dérèglement
climatique ensuite nous voulons que
notre droit soit respecté et que les
délais des procédures soient raccourcis
là encore je pense qu'une majorité peut
se dégager au sein de l'arc républicain
pour poursuivre ses objectifs
enfin et c'est l'objet je pense d'un
quasi consensus sur ses bancs nous
voulons mieux intégrer celles et ceux
que nous accueillons notamment par le
travail et par la langue mesdames et
messieurs les députés j'en suis
convaincu notre politique migratoire est
un équilibre un équilibre
hérité d'une histoire portée par des
valeurs et respectueux de l'État de
droit un équilibre entre le respect
ferme de la loi et l'intégration franche
de ceux à qui nous accordons le séjour
et l'asile un équilibre je suis certaine
que nous pourrons trouver ensemble je
vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre voilà
pour ce débat fleuve à l'Assemblée
nationale sur la politique de
l'immigration le projet de loi du
gouvernement sur le sujet est attendu
pour début 203 c'est la fin de cette
séance on se retrouve très bientôt sur
LCP pour un autre moment parlementaire